we've had our UPS and downs Chloe
thank you thank you
thank you Chloe goes on to say that it's a red flag
now this isn't her normal type of content
but I really applaud it um
because I think it's really
really important for people to be thinking like this
and not that it always is a red flag
and not that it always means something suspicious is happening
or something dubious is going on in the relationship
but just that people need to have a lens um
of understanding that abusive relationships are living and breathing amongst us
the monster myth is real it is a myth
it is there um
to ensure that men can keep getting away with abuse
and look and live and breathe like normal
decent human beings um
all while perpetrating in plain sight
we all get told that marriage is really hard work
and that we have to make compromises and sacrifices
and women especially get told this is
falls into the category of gendered advice
and at this point I think we always need to be asking is propaganda
because we have a lot of gender propaganda
lies myths
mistruths that have been told to us as we grow up
from the stage of being little girls um
that really set us up and condition us for a life of domestic servitude to men
intergenerational propaganda is absolutely essential to ensuring that any
power source can continue to perpetrate abuse
um any oppressor continue
can continue to oppress now
we live in a patriarchy it's intergenerational
we've lived in one for quite a long time now
um in order for a patriarchy to survive
just like in order for an oligarchy to survive
in order for a dictatorship to survive
um in order for a monarchy to survive
we need propaganda and brainwashing
so I'm here to debunk a lot of the brainwashing
just make people rethink a few things
not casting judgement on people
definitely not definitely not
um tryna make people's lives harder
just asking people to stay curious and to check in on themselves and each other
um stay safe out there girls love you